let's go to the phone 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
we're going to go to our caller from the
9 1 5 area code caller from 9 1 5 tell
us who you are where you're calling from
and what's on your mind today oh yeah
I'm Adrian I'm calling from El Paso
Texas great what's all this wondering
I'm in reference to Panna events origins
of totalitarianism in which she stated
that the ideal subject of totalitarian
rule is not the convinced Nazi or the
dedicated communist but from whom the
distinction between fact and fiction
true and false no longer exists and
given the current state of this whole
fake news phenomenon do you think that
the US government should step in and
find news outlets that spread false
information information that can easily
be negated by objective truth well
listen first of all it's the US
government that has created this frenzy
over so-called fake news so the last
thing I would do is appoint the
government of determining what's fake
and what's real news but the - Hannah
Aaron's point it's so related to the
world that is described in Aldous
Huxley's brave new world right which is
not the government controls the
messaging and is propaganda or whatever
the case may be although there certainly
probably plenty of government propaganda
it's that it becomes impossible to know
what is real and what is not and it is
within that confusion that so many bad
things very serious things as the
president likes to say are able to take
place so I think that there's a really
good connection there I mean as far as
the government that's stepping in and
saying here is the approved list of
media outlets that is an absolute and
total disaster I don't think that's a
good idea Adrian I mean I don't know if
you were asking hypothetically or
rhetorically or if you you think that
that might be a good thing hey I was
just asking
hypothetically okay yeah I would be
against the Trump administration or any
government deciding who are the real
news outlets Adrian thank you very
important question particularly in 2017
Trump's America